many Europeans are stranded abroad
because of the coronavirus crisis
flights have been suspended and borders
have been closed and they do not know
how the situation will evolve at this
stage more than 100,000 men women and
children have already expressed their
wish to come back as soon as possible we
are here to help them return home we
work closely with national governments
on this European diplomats around the
globe provide assistance right now
we help organise 13 flights to
repatriate Europeans from Egypt Morocco
Philippines Tunisia Argentina you name
it there will be more than 3000 on board
and in addition we are getting ready to
bring home Europeans from Peru maladies
Mongolia and many African countries in
the past two days we have repatriated
hundreds of EU citizens from Morocco
there were Austrians and other EU
citizens on board as well as Swiss
Bosnian and US citizens from the
beginning of the coronavirus we have
repatriated approximately thousand two
hundred you citizens for example from
Japan and the United States in times
like this it's good to be part of a
strong community our European Union